everybody welcome to live coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie and today we're going
to look at a chrome dev tools light
house audit of this react project that
we've been working on and I've been away
for a while and I've been sick but I'm
getting better so I'm gonna try not to
coughing ah during this this dream but
I'm still not 100% so I'm pretty tired
so if I'm if I'm a little off I'm gonna
blame it on Pat my illness I don't
really know what it was
flu or cold or something but but I'm
starting to get better now so let me let
me start off by just showing you in dev
tools where the audit is this is
actually pretty easy to do and it's a
good way to just kind of check out like
what's going on with your website in
terms of a lot of different factors so
there we go okay so on the screen now
this is just chrome dev tools I'm
running it in dark mode and I've also
extended it out to take up the full
screen so I'll just click that option
there and you can see this is the
website that we've run this on this is
dev dot Franciscan University and I
updated this earlier today with the
latest changes I did do a few more
things after I updated so it's not
exactly like what I'm running locally
but it's it's pretty close so
let me get started we do have a question
let's answer this Marcus asked if the
recordings are available yeah all the
live coding sessions are all recorded
and available on the free code camp
YouTube channel I also have some stuff
available on my channel the link to
that's in the description okay so I
figured we're just gonna go down through
all the pieces of advice that lighthouse
gives us and we just kind of comment on
it think about what we can do to improve
and hopefully it'll make this site a lot
better but also maybe give you some
ideas for your own sites all right so
first thing we're going to look at is
performance so you can see here are my
scores on the only thing I was really
surprised about was this accessibility
score being so high because we haven't
really focused that much on
accessibility beyond like the normal
things so so that's pretty good I
definitely still want to go through and
try to get this number you know as high
as possible but performance was also a
little bit of a surprise but we'll see
in a second why it makes a lot of sense
why the performance is bad right now
sorry the on so let's go through weren't
you running on it you can go through
each category so we're going to start
with performance which we get a 49 out
of 100 and it gives you a lot of useful
information so just to let you know it
tells you
we're the constraints put on this so we
are emulating a mobile a mobile phone
loading this we can do desktop if we
wanted but we're doing mobile and that's
the default and it's on a 3G network
with a slow CPU so there are a lot of
different is that the oil I assume there
were different options it's not showing
me any but maybe there's some way to do
different options but this is pretty
good to do it this way and that way for
users that have better conditions great
they're gonna have a wonderful
experience but for your users that don't
have the optimal conditions then they'll
get a good experience if that's what
you're optimizing for so you minimize
that portion of your users that are
gonna have to wait a long time for your
site to load so this is I think this is
a good idea all right so the first thing
we have these metrics it shows us what
the user sees at various points of
loading so it's this in seconds so two
point let me zoom in if I can this girl
let me zoom No okay so just leave it
like this so at two point six seconds
we're still seeing white up until then
and then we see text and UI elements but
no image it's not until the five point
two second mark that we see an image on
the screen and so at that point it's not
it's not too bad because everything we
want to use you to see on this part of
the screen is visible but still it took
5.2 seconds to get there so don't like
that I don't really like that it took
2.6 seconds for them to see anything at
all so we'll see what we can do so this
this first metric is going to say first
meaningful paint
now it's giving it to us in milliseconds
but you know we're gonna say that's you
know what about three and a half seconds
here and if you don't know what these
mean they give you an explanation and
they even give you a link to learn more
so you could definitely you'll go
through this even if you don't know that
much about it and click on the links
read through it and you'll have a pretty
good idea what's going on first
meaningful paint though is just when
there's enough content on the page that
you know it's a website you know users
you can see like what's going on with
your content first interactive in the
sand this is in beta so you know we'll
see whether or not this is that accurate
or not but this is when the page will be
interactive so think about like when we
would click when a user would click on
this menu scroll over like on this side
now you know it it may not do anything
before that a second mark right so
that's that's kind of an issue a user
might click on that and think it's
broken hmm sorry I thought I was well
enough to do the stream I'm so tired
and then consistently interactive gotta
wait for 16 seconds you see it's showing
us even with these lines on the on the
timeline here where that happens so you
know these these I'm not not happy about
these these metrics I would be upset if
that was my user experience on the
website so here's the good part the
opportunities because now we figure out
what can I do to change these metrics so
first thing is off screen images and I
love this idea and it's lazy loading the
off screen and
images to improve your page load speed
and time interactive and it actually
gives us all the images that we could
lazy load and then tells us you know our
savings which in this case since we lazy
load the image like the entire image
size would be saved right so each one of
these images could be lazy loaded and
they must go through even on a desktop
you can see I only see one image here
unless you want to count this think I'm
loading this as an SVG I don't remember
how we did that but I think it is but
anyway we don't even see any images
until we scroll down a bit further this
is a video this is the first image so
there's no need to have all these images
load up right away once the user starts
scrolling and then we might want to say
oh a you know let's start loading those
images because we need them now but we
could definitely save a bit of time with
that normally your images are your your
largest elements of your page oh hey I
see if you you're saying hi in there hey
John how's it going 1s about the links
in the description yeah the link to my
youtube channel is in the description so
I have my own channel where I do some
some tutorial videos and livestreams as
well in case you're interested so I
think that's a great idea
and I'm gonna add this I have a just a
little checklist on my other screen and
as we go through I'm gonna add some some
- dues which will eventually turn into
github issues and we'll try to work
through some of those to get the site
ready and fast you know faster than it
is now and I've been working to cut down
on the number of issues and fix some
things and close them out so if you've
been
checking out the github repo lately you
may have seen the B law issues going
down but here we're gonna say all right
so I know you can't see my other screen
I'm not gonna switch you over just so
you can see a checklist I don't think
that's it's really that exciting but
basically I'm just saying lazy load the
images especially on the home page the
home page really is the most image heavy
page that we have so far on the site so
and that's the page that most users are
going to come to so we want that to be
to give we want to give the most
attention to that page you know most of
our users probably won't even see any of
the interior pages and I'm gonna make a
note to maybe use source set for this
which is like an HTML attribute where
you can specify different images for
different screen sizes okay
so that's good so just with these two
things I imagine we could bring our
score up significantly but let's check
out a few of the other things we can do
serve images and next gem formats and
this is interesting I've never used any
of these formats so they're saying
instead of using your regular paying
your JPEG you can use JPEG 2000 JPEG XR
and WebP II I actually have only heard
of WebP e I haven't even heard of these
newer forms of JPEG so that's something
that I'm gonna want to look into so I'm
gonna put it on the list but I need to
do some research before I do that mainly
I would need to know is it supported by
browsers if it is supported then I need
to figure out how to do it larger than
it needs to be so it looks like we can
cut down this image significantly and
potentially save 91% now Harrison could
still be cut down by 59% so we can
definitely save just by resizing our
images we could save a lot we're
probably gonna end up doing is trying to
do some sort of replacement of images
based on screen width so one a very
large screen where we would want a
bigger image will load that image and
then honest miss is a large image right
now
so I probably I took this and didn't do
anything to cut it down so I definitely
want to do that even these images which
are much smaller by comparing like a
mobile where it's a waste to have a
really large image then we'll really
load the small one so I'm gonna make a
note of that as well to say
now again images we can cut down
the size of images so this alumni
profile image which is this image here
so this one's a maybe so I'm just gonna
say look into using web P and they may
have reduced render blocking style
sheets so it looks like we we have one
render blocking stylesheet and this is
for our fonts so we are loading our font
in the head potentially we could load it
lower down the page you know that's
something we might maybe we think about
going mmm I will have to experiment with
that one because I will obviously I want
the font to be used the correct font but
do we really need do we need that phone
right away if we could give the user
something on the screen immediately or
you know less than one second even if
it's not the right font would that be
better and then whenever the font does
load it just switches over you know I
think that would be a better user
experience it would be a little bit of a
change but at least they would see
something on the screen it would appear
that the page is loaded very quickly so
I'm gonna look into that I I remember
seeing a talk where they were talking
about doing just that we're loading a
back up front first and then loading the
other font I don't know if that's
something that's supported right now or
if that talk was about things that will
be possible in the future so I'm gonna
have to find that and and figure that
out so that's gonna be another one where
I'm just gonna research
Oh Annie keys in the chat has it going
[Music]
so the font thing I recently did on my
blog helps a lot thanks for that retweet
on the keyboard shortcuts by the way oh
yeah no problem
okay
so it looks like we have some options
there for that font then okay cool so
we'll have to have to do that oh I'll
make an issue out of it and then
whatever ideas you all have about the
font you know we can discuss it on a
github issue
all right so I made a little note for me
to remember to make an issue out of that
oh I see in John says react image and
react visibility sensor our well-known
image components for handling image
cache and loading all cool very cool
awesome
I'm definitely have to check that out
thank you John alright so we only have
one more here on our opportunities for
our performance and that's to remove
unused rules from style sheets so this
isn't a huge deal right we're talking
about a 10 millisecond improvement so 10
milliseconds is incredibly fast I'm not
sure that it's worth it to take out this
bit of code so I'm not going to even
worry about this for now you know there
is such a thing as like over optimizing
right you know we're gonna take these
things that are gonna be huge
improvements and do those for sure and
then we'll we'll try again and we'll see
what score we get we'll see what the
user experience is like you know it may
not be worth blowing through our CSS and
removing things and then making sure it
hasn't messed something else up just for
10 milliseconds all right and then we
have Diagnostics and so like we can see
all of our all the things that are being
loaded and we see how long it takes to
transfer those total size I mean look at
this six and a half seconds for that one
image right that's if we fix this thing
up I mean we're definitely gonna
increase the performance and decrease
the load times and that's not even to
talk about this image here which I don't
think has been sized properly or
compressed
so we definitely can can do some work
with that all right so our caching
policy is no good now this is on these
images right now these images well the
fonts are we don't have any control over
the fonts for right now because they're
coming from Google phones but this is
coming from Franciscan dot e-d-u
so these are actually being served from
the University from the campus they're
one of the some of the servers that that
are there on the campus so we've already
switched these over all these images
over to Google cloud servers so I
haven't switched the URL that we're
getting these from but I will switch
that soon so we may be able to improve
through each one of these these are
getting down into like more details of
what we're gonna do but you can see
there's just so much information I mean
I look I proved this without doing
anything
we'll see what Google has set so this
could kind of be a freebie that will be
better critical request chains so around
like for the last five years or
something because you know I used to go
to different websites to try to get this
information but I could never get all of
this information in such detail all
together at one time this is just really
amazing and then we could see all the
things that we pass if you know if we
really want to feel happy about it we
can look the things we did really well
so I'm not gonna look at them right now
for time but it is kind of cool to look
at in case you're feeling down about all
the things that are messed up on your
site just you know take a look down here
you know give yourself a pat on the back
all right so we're gonna go we're to
check out this progressive web app now
oh by the way I think I'm I'm just gonna
go through this and then that'll be the
end for the stream today it's kind of
late
and you know I'm still not a hundred
percent you know better yet so in future
streams we'll definitely go through some
of this and actually do the work to make
it better and then eventually we'll do
another audit to make sure that we
actually improves but not for today's
stream so if anybody was did really want
to see some coding stuff probably not
gonna see any coding today it's just
gonna be all about going through
lighthouse how do we interpret the data
we get from lighthouse and some ideas
for how to act on that okay so if you're
not sure what a progressive web app is
I'll give you just a quick overview a
progressive web app uses a cool feature
in browsers now in JavaScript called a
serviceworker so a serviceworker is a
JavaScript file that runs in the the
client side and the user's browser and
it can intercept network requests so the
network request normally would go from
the user's browser and to the server
with potentially things in between like
CD ends or things like that but this
sits in between that so a network
request would go to the serviceworker
first right wouldn't even you leave the
user's computer wouldn't even leave
their browser and then the serviceworker
can determine what it's going to do with
that request right so potentially let's
say you cache a lot of data already the
service work that could take that
request and say hey you know what we
already have all this data so we're just
gonna give you the data right away I'm
not even gonna send this request back to
the server and imagine how fast that
would be to get the response so a
progressive web app number one is very
fast but also could potentially enable
your app to work offline so there's
going to be some features of your app
that can work without an internet
connection and then for those
features that need a connection as the
connection it comes available and
becomes better your app will
progressively get more functionality
right so that's what we're going for
here now right now you can see we only
have a score of 55 so we're not doing
what we need to do so let's let's check
out what's happening number one we don't
register server workers so service
workers so that's a big deal right so we
need to figure out why we're not
registering a service worker and
obviously we're not responding properly
when we're offline so we're not prompted
to install the app so a lot of these are
all basically because we don't have that
Service Worker running okay but there's
no no manifest so maybe that's the best
place for us to look for this is that if
we don't have the correct data and/or
manifest
we're not that all of this isn't going
to work so so for my note for this
section for this whole section I'm just
gonna say let's make sure that manifest
is correct and then we can run it again
and see how much of this is is gonna
work because the I think a lot of these
issues will be solved if we have the
correct manifest hey if we fix the
manifest and we're still having issues
that we know it's something else but I
don't want to dig too far into these
without testing that first so that's
gonna be our first step you can see we
did pass some things right so we do have
some content when Java scripts not
available that's probably because of our
server-side rendering it which is
definitely a good thing not just for SEO
we use HTTP we redirect HTTP our page
load is fast enough on 3G which as slow
as it is it's still fast enough
we have meta viewport tag and the
content is sized correctly for the
viewpoint right so all of these have
nothing to do with our service workers
so that leads me to believe even more
that all these problems are due to our
service worker not firing up and I think
that stems from our manifest as well
but we'll check that out in future
streams or maybe I'll check it out you
know on my own and then just let you
know what what happened with that on the
stream well we do have things to
manually check this pose so siteworx
cross browser well interesting okay so
it's it's saying you test in other
browsers which it's definitely good
make sure page transitions don't feel
like they block on the network okay in
each page has a URL cool we do this
definitely each page does feel like it
as a URL clicking around the site this
looks good
tell you truth I haven't tested on a lot
of different browsers yet so that's
something I'm definitely going to need
to do we can have a lot of users test
and then we can also use browser stack
to test browsers all right from the same
computer we can test in a lot of
different browsers and operating systems
even mobile right through our our
browser really useful it's a monthly
service but it's definitely it's it's
worth it
you know for you know my organization to
have that it's definitely worth it all
right let me check the live chat now
since we're gotten through the first two
scores I'm gonna check this and just
make sure I'm not missing anything
Schoop um says get well soon thank you
thank you I appreciate it
I hope I'm getting well soon because I'm
I'm taking the family on a vacation on
Friday so we're gonna I'm gonna leave
Friday night drive all through the night
well hopefully all the kids can sleep
and then we're gonna we're gonna end up
and going to the beach in Virginia so
anybody in Virginia Beach area you know
let me know if there's any meetups or
anything going on next week I'll be
there for a whole week but if I'm still
not feeling well it's gonna be rough to
drive through the night so hopefully I'm
better let's see well Jeff says glad I
caught a little bit of a stream of day
was wondering why I didn't see you last
couple of days get well thanks Jeff I
appreciate it
John says for anyone who needs to deal
with large images on a site image
editing [ __ ] its aggressive JPEG
compression plus removal of unnecessary
file code done with full live image view
it's a must or full page image cool I
and I I use [ __ ] for editing it's a free
program so I'm definitely gonna check
that out Jacob asked what browser I'm
using now I'm using Chrome which is
recently updated so whatever the latest
version of Chrome is for for Mac for the
latest Mac operating system that's what
I'm using
Aniki says this next shay ass have a
cookie cutter way to enable
serviceworker
create react react app has it baked in
and gasps she makes it super easy yeah
it i thought next did have it baked in
so i'm not sure what happened with that
i'm gonna have to double check and see
maybe some of the custom server things
we did messed up the automatic stuff or
maybe i'm just mistaken
next doesn't have it automatically baked
in and Jacob asks how I got the dark
mode yeah so if you go into settings
under theme to preferences and then
appearance theme you can switch from
dark to light so I always keep it on
dark okay
Oh Nikki says image öktem is good for a
Mac and Jacob asks about tiny PNG com
you know I've used a lot of different
things but what I've mainly used is on
the command line I've used image magic
and I find that it's very powerful if
you have a lot of images if I only have
one image I will open it up in something
like [ __ ] and edit it you know by hand
but if I have a ton of images like
hundreds of images a command line tool
is way more powerful you can just set
the parameters of exactly how you want
the images resize or cropped or
compressed and just batch convert all
those images so there's a ton of
different options with imagemagick I
mean I found with imagemagick if
something is possible to do with an
image there's a way to do it it just
takes a little bit of research and
reading the docs which are extensive but
it's a very cool command-line tool and
since it runs on the command line you
can even make it part of your build
process you know if you wanted to so I
definitely recommend that for for batch
image processing all right let's check
out our accessibility school now which
as I mentioned earlier I was I was
pleasantly surprised at this I
definitely I have an uncle who is blind
and is still like very active in terms
of learning new things and being on the
internet everything so it's something
that because of that I may be a little
bit more aware about and I think about
it more but I still think I could do a
much better job at making things
accessible so an accessibility isn't
just about those who are you know
completely blind there's there's a whole
different there's a whole range of
different accessibility issues but I
think this is great that this is
included in here so let's check this out
we have some iframe issues and the
iframe doesn't have a title this is
probably in our our videos right so the
this YouTube video is loading in an
iframe I don't think I put any iframes
on the page other than that so we can
definitely fix that by adding elements
to our iframes what I've actually was
thinking about doing is setting this up
I love that we can load this these
videos right here and have them be so
like available but I really would rather
like try to lazy load them or do
something because we we are loading all
the stuff we need to play this video
right away and we definitely don't need
to so that's another thing that maybe
I'll just look add to our lazy load
images and all add an video if possible
but then also let's make a note I'm
gonna make a note about adding we're
gonna add say title
so we're gonna add a title attribute to
those iframes all right it actually
shows you the elements and if we could
see the screen over over here when we
did that it would it would highlight the
area on the screen we can hover over and
it'll show us and in fact those are the
the two iframes are both the YouTube
iframes so that's that's what's causing
the issue
so that's night that's an easy fix so
that's it's good when when it's
straightforward we know exactly what to
do to fix it let's check out this color
contrast I was a little bit surprised by
this but it makes sense so I'll show you
the failing elements on the other screen
but it says that there's a low contrast
text it's difficult or impossible for
many users to read so let's check this
out and what the texts are talking about
is this text so I was a little surprised
about it but then once I thought about
it I remembered you know what I have had
people complain about this text before
and we actually made it darker at one
point but evidently we didn't make it
dark enough and it's still hard to read
so we're gonna have to think about a
different color here either darkening
the color even more or replacing it with
a different color you know maybe this
could be that that green color or our
gold color you know so we can switch it
out for a different color in the in our
color palette but you know this this
color is not gonna work so not just here
probably anywhere we use this throughout
the site this is gonna have to change
and so that's like I said accessibility
is not just about people who are blind I
mean right it's about people just not
everybody has the vision to be able to
see this for me I can see and it looks
fine other people might look at that and
not be able to make out what that is so
we're gonna make a note
change that yellow color everywhere okay
let's say elements are well structured
so in this section we're looking at the
structure and we say here we we actually
have a list so those lists do not
contain only Li elements and Script
supporting elements so it's the screen
readers have a specific way of
announcing lists so we need a proper
list structure it's gonna mess up the
screen readers so this is what it's
talking about here this section so let's
inspect this and see what's going on
switch over to our elements here so our
list is yeah we're just start okay
here's our UL so within our UL we
shouldn't have divs these should all be
l eyes so we've messed up something in
this component and I expect I suspect
that maybe this is not by default in
material UI I would think they wouldn't
do something like this this is probably
something custom that that I did at some
point without realizing the impact that
it would have on accessibility so you
know we have a component for this we'll
need to just go in and check it out so
I'm just gonna make a note to say make
sure this component
as proper ul Li structure okay so I
think basically if we were to just take
all these div tags and make sure that
they were allies instead of divs that
would solve the problem
let's go back to our audits scroll back
down to where we were and really I mean
think about if if we fix that then or at
least our homepage potentially could get
a hundred percent score on accessibility
which is awesome right of course we'd
have to look at our other pages and make
sure that we're still it's still
accessible but you know that's that's
pretty good now I'm not sure if this
looked at our menu our side menu or not
so that would be something that we would
want to make sure was definitely
accessible that's important and you can
see we pass a lot of audits as well so
we're using our attributes correctly
following best practices for Aria yeah
so that's really cool we have some
things that aren't applicable so
probably elements that we didn't use and
then there's a lot of things to check so
need to go through and and either check
these myself or have somebody else check
these you know to just go through the
page and hit the tab button and see like
does this even make sense of where the
tab is focusing right try to use
keyboard stuff a lot of these have to do
with the focus on the screen oh this
would be a visual order on the page
follows dumb order right so a screen
reader is going to read through
your dom tree right and if you have it
all out of order and i've used let's say
like CSS to change the order on the page
it would make sense if you're looking at
it looking at the UI but it's not going
to make sense of the screen readers
going through it so keep that in mind
and we'll have to check that out for
this project headings don't skip levels
that's a good one that's when we're
gonna have trouble with for a lot of
those interior pages where we've pulled
over some badly formatted formatted
content so we'll kinda have to slowly go
through those and fix that cool all
right last one left is best practices
I'm gonna check the chat again before we
go into that let's see a little bit more
activity in there okay John Hanson says
take lots of vitamin d3 and a good multi
B that will help you get your energy up
from being sick
okay cool I've been taking a lot of B
vitamins I'll have to often make sure
I'm getting D vitamins I just ran out of
my multivitamin like two days ago or
something so maybe I have to get some
more a Michael creoles here says sorry I
was taking a nap don't worry about it I
wish I was taking a nap too
John Henson says are you using CSS
variables for your colors easier to
tweak globally yes some of them Niki's
is there they're there in the jss theme
yeah so changing those colors will
probably fix a lot of it there may be
some places where I like manually put
the color in in a stylesheet somewhere
so I'll have to double check that but I
mean that that'll be as simple as you're
strolling a you know find and replace
globally throughout the project michael
says some of the accessibility rules
seem weird until you actually use a
screen reader like Chrome box then you
understand what's lacking yeah actually
that's a great idea that might not maybe
it'll be a good stream to try to do one
day where we go through one of our
projects with a screen reader and like
listen to what it's saying just to get
that that experience Nietzsche says when
doing accessibility work use the ax so
it's a capital X e the dev tools plug-in
it's awesome are off to check that out
I've never even heard of that
Matt Dutchess says feel better be
vitamins and airborne see Kim is amazing
for colds all right I'll have to check
that out I haven't heard of that I do
have airborne I need to take it and
thank you all right let's get through
this last section here best practices so
we got a pretty good score there I mean
that's awesome but we failed two things
so let's check out the manifests short
name will be truncated to and displayed
on home screen so make your apps short
name fewer than 12 characters
okay that seems like an easy fix right
we just have our name is too long so
that doesn't seem like it'll be a big
deal
and we have errors log to the console
they come from Network requests failures
[Music]
interesting all right it looks like we
may have been trying to prefetch some of
this I think probably the it was trying
to prefetch these pages and then somehow
it wasn't working properly it may
actually be tied into our progressive
web app stuff not working and when
loading route yeah and these are the
same things with the routes and then we
also have some stuff with our manifest
so it says it failed to load it but then
it also says that there's an unexpected
token so I think all of these might be
able to be fixed by fixing the our
manifest JSON so that's probably gonna
solve just fixing that it's gonna solve
a lot of our issues so we may be able to
get that up to a hundred percent just by
that oops I forgot SEO sorry I said this
was the last one and it's definitely not
we passed a lot of stuff so I'm not
gonna go through it all but you just
check some of these other things that
they consider best practices all right
this is actually cool avoid front-end
JavaScript libraries with known security
vulnerabilities that's kind of a big one
I know a lot of my older sites were you
know you you check them now and it's
like this thing is
not secure right it's a lot of times we
build sites and then we don't maintain
them you know they may be maintained by
someone else where they may never be
maintained again you know your your
contracts up with the client and you're
done right and the client said you know
well hey my site still alert it's fine
so there are a lot of front-end
JavaScript libraries out there that are
insecure that are still on the sites you
know because of that it's cool to see
that we don't have that issue okay so
let's check our SEO so this is search
engine optimization and colony key says
is that an anti jQuery rule yeah I
didn't want to go there I didn't want to
call out jQuery specifically but yeah
that's what I was thinking of it seems
like there are a lot of versions of
jQuery that are considered insecure so
yeah that's definitely something to
watch out for but search engine
optimization in case you're not familiar
with that that has to do with how high
you rank on search page usually
everybody worries about Google search
rightly so they're the largest search
engine by far if you're okay on Google
search you're probably going to be okay
on other search engines so we usually
want to rank as high as possible we want
to be on that first page of the Google
search as high up as possible and so
that's where the SEO comes in that's a
big part of it so let's check out what
we're doing wrong so document does not
have a Meta Description all right we
didn't include a Meta Description okay
so not not really hard to fix you just
have to make sure we include that links
do not have descriptive text so we have
one link that does not have descriptive
text so we did we did a good job of
putting this stuff in but we didn't on
about our mission so
we'll just have to put that in and you
know what I forgot to make a note so
let's meta descriptions and
[Music]
what was that page our mission alright
and let's see this one document doesn't
use a legible font sizes it says what
was at forty forty two point three
percent of text is too small and very
helpfully it tells us exactly what is
too small so we have some stuff at 13
pixels so I'm at fourteen everything
needs to be greater than or equal to
sixteen where this is was a bit
surprising to me because I'm always
about larger font sizes but let's see
where we went wrong here so I'm thinking
here mainly I never fixed this because I
had always thought that I would redo
this component anyway so I just kind of
left it as is I didn't really like it it
looks like this font might be a bit
small and this is another component
where I didn't think I was going to keep
it like this as well but it seems like
seems like everything else is at least
sixteen so I expect it's probably almost
everything within this card and then
maybe this here which that's not a big
deal because I was already planning on
updating or removing some of these but I
will make a note just to make sure that
all fonts are at least 16 pixels
all right and let's see these things
that we passed all right we get that
meta viewport tag we have a title
element stat good status codes we are
not blocking anything from indexing
believe it or not I've had clients
websites where they I go in and check
out their site and realize that they're
actually blocking from their block from
being indexed so whoever had built the
site previously or worked on the site
had stopped it from being indexed so you
know they wondered whether SEO wasn't
you know it wasn't doing well and that's
that's why great so you have those
here's some of the things to check out
page is mobile-friendly right definitely
we could do this mobile-friendly test
I'm not going to do it right now and we
know the site's mobile-friendly we've
been developing with that in mind all
along but we'll probably end up doing
this test at some point structured data
is valid so we can we'll see use a
testing tool to check out our structured
data so not bad definitely want to run
this again after we've done some more
because you know when you have some
changes to make on the front page but
look you know definitely with our images
and things with our videos or fonts we
still have to put content down here you
know we have our our bacon if some text
here so there's gonna be content here
that'll need to be checked that we
haven't even done yet
and I imagine we're gonna have different
content here potentially even more
content if we set up that lazy loading
it shouldn't be an issue though but this
gives us a really good look now at this
point in the development of what we're
doing right so that we should keep doing
it and what we need to improve on but
overall you know I'm I'm pretty
confident we can get all of these scores
up significantly there's nothing in here
that I'm like scratching my head at
how are we gonna do that you know
everything we've got a plan for
everything you know sometimes that plan
is just let's do a little research on
this but I I definitely think we can get
that accessibility up to 100 we can get
those best practices up to a hundred
there's no reason why we couldn't get
the SEO up to 100 as well if we fix that
manifest this should be a hundred the
performance is the only thing that I'm
saying maybe not a hundred the reason
being we have those YouTube embeds and I
know every time I've used the YouTube
embed it's been impossible to get up to
100 so in unless we figure out some way
to lazy load those I don't think we're
gonna have a hundred percent but we'll
see so I'm really excited to get to work
on these and then rerun this and see it
you know it's kind of like a little game
to see what you can get I will say this
though kind of just as a as a cautionary
note be careful about getting too caught
up into getting hundreds and everything
right the first things you do will be
really easy and you'll gain a lot but
then that difference between like a 95
and 100 is gonna take a lot of work and
from a user standpoint they may not even
notice the difference
so while it'd be really fun to get all
hundreds and it'd be cool when I would
screenshot it you know nobody really
cares about that your users don't care
what your score is it just needs to be
fast to them and that's all that really
matters so the numbers give you a good
guide as to what you do to make it
faster but at the end of the day like
get out your phone test it out emulate a
slow network test it out if it's fast
then it's fast you know whether it's a
95 or 100 it doesn't matter just make
sure it's fast all right so I'm just
gonna go back and do some
questions and just talk with you out for
a little bit before we end this dream
and let me know especially if you have
any questions about anything we've got
over with with this audit or with dev
tools you know definitely let me know
but also open any other questions as
well
Michael Creole says setting up a
manifest.json file takes a minute or two
that's awesome that's good to hear
that's it that's gonna be a huge
improvement in our score just setting
that up Shubham says is there any tool
which can give us a hint about all this
while developing I don't know of any
tool but that's a great idea
like a nice like editor plugin
or extension that that could do that I
mean that would be awesome I mean some
of it yeah some of it would have to be a
browser plugin and then some of it could
be done with an editor plugin but a lot
of it I think could be done that way
that's a great idea
michael says audits are like a
whack-a-mole game for des yeah for sure
nikki says hints while developing
linting setup yeah yeah that's that's
definitely true you could set some
linting rules to help you make sure a
lot of the mark-up stuff is correct so
some of this stuff where you're making
sure that certain attributes are on
certain elements that could be a limping
thing for sure actually not what I think
about now that we're talking about it I
just want to check and see that
manifest.json I want to see if we have
it so alright let me make this bigger I
know that's probably way too small for
everyone to see right now which just
being our static pages static would we
want to put our manifest.json in our
static files or is that created in our
building with a manifest Jas oh yeah
that can't be it no that can't be it all
right build manifest.json
that's not what I want
ages manifest.json so we have other
types of manifest files but I don't
think we have the the manifest file that
we need so that definitely explains a
lot I'll have to look up the format and
what all I need for that all right let's
see Shubham says can you briefly explain
how do we do page indexing for SEO and
how it works well the search engine will
take care of indexing so you just want
to make sure that your page is readable
by search engine so if you're using
something like react that does you know
that could potentially do everything on
the client side you want to make sure
you have server-side routing as well so
that the browser can get HTML that it
can read instead of just some JavaScript
because it won't wait around for your
JavaScript to make API calls and get
data back it'll just assume that
whatever it sees at first is what your
page is and so you basically it'll think
you have a blank page or mostly blank
page you know make sure you have title
tags you know descriptions meta tags
your descript meta descriptions as well
proper use of heading tags is important
so there's a lot of factors that go in
SEO and it's like a whole field all on
its own so you know definitely you know
check in to what the latest best
practices are but in terms of your web
development you just want to make sure
that the search edge of the search
engine you know BOTS the the crawlers
right that they have going out there and
indexing pages that they can actually
see your content and you know mainly
through server-side rendering that's
that's your best way to handle that
Alberto says hi Jesse do you have any
advice for how to work with a brand
whose color palette is not matched
product specifically it is an Employment
Services site and the palette is lime
green do the best you can with your
color palette and I would try to make
use of white space a lot so you know you
can kind of like we've done here if the
color palette doesn't look great
on on a screen which I don't think the
Franciscan color palette looks great so
you know it wasn't designed to look good
online it was designed before right
there was a you know the internet right
so we make use of white space a lot of
white space right we have a clean theme
and then we just use some of the colors
here and there as highlights right so
like that gold color that we see kind of
here and on the outline of things it
doesn't look great in a huge block it
looked kind of dingy if you have a huge
block of it so we only use it as a trim
and it looks really nice
you sparingly so maybe you might want to
think about doing something like that
maybe using you know seeing how far you
can play with the the color right and
the hues you know that might be a good
idea as well so it does kind of depend
on how much leeway you you'll have to to
work with those colors change them a
little bit maybe yeah I don't I don't
know exactly what that situation is but
if you got some colors that aren't great
to work with and just use white as much
as possible or if you're doing a dark
theme use like the black or really dark
grey as much as possible
Oh
Aniki says use ctrl P and the editor to
search for it that's a great idea
wonderful
note we don't have a manifest.json all
right cool definitely need to do that
all right michael says if we had when it
would be in the root okay good to know
Umberto's says it looks kind of like a
lawn care or recycling color scheme
customer once the colors reflected in
the site alright I would if the customer
wants the colors in the site then I
would I would use plenty of white space
or if you want to go dark theme use you
know the dark space right but use the
colors in key areas where they're
visible but it's not a ton of the colors
and definitely you know let let your
client know the benefits of having all
that white space you know maybe look up
some statistics or studies if you if you
need to about you know the user being
able to focus on the text more and on
the content of the site if you can try
to have concrete evidence to back up
your decisions right so if you if you do
go in and say like this color is
terrible like that's not gonna work but
instead don't even talk about their
color explain why white is so awesome
and will he'll be helpful right and it
takes the focus away from something
negative about their colors and it
spends it as something positive and
maybe you could even give examples of
other sites that do well that utilize a
lot of white even maybe like well-known
brands who have well-known color schemes
and if they still use a lot of white on
their site like you know things like
that so hopefully the client likes what
you do and you don't have to do any of
that but just be prepared to explain the
benefits of you know a design without a
lot of color if you need to
and the bottom line is if the client
really wants that color all over the
place and it turns out ugly you know you
can just do it get paid and don't put
your name on it leave it out of your
portfolio I mean I understand how it is
sometimes you got to pay the bills so at
the end of the day if the client really
demands that even though you tell them
that's against your you know your
suggestions of what's best for the site
then you know that's that's what you got
to do now if if you don't need the money
right now then you could be choosy and
say okay find somebody else to do it
but most people don't have that luxury
and I totally understand that you know
you you know you gotta get the job you
gotta get it done and get paid
let's see Michael says I talked to Nicki
about this but I'm having problems with
a lack of motivation so I like watching
your streams to try to get it back three
weeks and Counting now maybe why I bug
you are there oh don't worry about
bugging me that was I was cool I'm like
I was happy that you were you know
checking in on me so yeah I definitely
understand about lack of motivation I
struggle with that too and the streams
help me as well
you know I I don't want to come on a
stream every day and have nothing done
from the previous stream right I want to
get things done and be able to you know
have progress in the project and have
new things to talk about with you all so
I totally understand that motivation can
be hard sometimes I don't know the best
thing is you just get a project that
you're excited about you know some or
you know some new thing you're learning
that you're really into and that seems
to help me get motivated and you know
sometimes exercise helps for me like
caffeine helps sometimes people react
differently to caffeine so that might
not work for everybody
and you know sometimes sometimes you
just she's got to do it like there are
some things that it wouldn't doesn't
exactly get you excited or really that
motivated but it'll help you to just get
the job done like you know I I need to
do this because I need to get paid I'm
not gonna be able to pay my bills or if
I don't do this my boss is gonna be
upset with me or you know anything like
that it's not like positive
reinforcement but if it if it get you to
get the Lord done it's still good you
know you don't want to always have that
you know to rely on but it's a nice
back-up plan like all right well if I
can't get myself motivated all these
nice ways at least I'll be afraid to
mess up and that'll be my motivation so
that can help now I know for some people
like giving updates on social media
about their progress helps because it's
like if I tell people I'm gonna do this
and then I don't do it then you know
that everybody's gonna know I didn't do
it that can help some people as well it
could probably hurt some people too I
mean if people struggle with anxiety
that may not be the best thing to do but
it does work for some nikki says
couldn't help a lot here sadly also in
general it's super easy to get
overwhelmed yeah it is it is I yeah
there are a couple times recently where
I felt overwhelmed which is the amount
of work that still needs to be done on
this project and I'm working on another
project so I don't know if you all have
ever been to the site balance I oh it's
it's like a crypto wallet site they're
coming out with an app and they're using
react native to build it so I've been
working on that and so you know it's
like on top of all the other
things I have this which is really fun
and I like working on it
but it's just one other thing that we
kind of overwhelmed about so the best
thing that that I can do what I feel
overwhelmed it's just like have a to-do
list and just say I'm gonna do this one
thing and then I get focused and I do
one thing and I get it done and it feels
good to get that done and then I move on
and I move on right I could just chip
away it forces me to stop looking at the
big picture and focus on something
little and manageable and usually I can
start to get my mind focused where it
needs to be and that overwhelming
feeling goes away okay all right well
I'm done with the questions for the
stream also I forgot to mention earlier
and maybe I'll bring it up on another
stream as well since there's not that
many people watching right now but I was
one of the individuals selected as a top
contributor for free code camp so I'm
really honored about that and so they're
having several like I don't know parties
for the top contributors so think around
August 18th August are somewhere around
August 18th I'll be in New York City so
if anybody is in New York you know maybe
I'll get to hang out but just want to
throw that out there in case anybody is
anybody's interested and then meeting up
or anything like that so oh thanks John
John said congratulations yeah thank you
it was really awesome to be selected all
right cool so yeah I'll try to stream
tomorrow I know it's gonna be busy
trying to get everything ready to go for
vacation and get everything make sure I
have everything done that I need to get
done at the office before
leave but I'm definitely gonna try to
stream because I most likely won't
stream during vacation so in case
something happens and I can't stream the
rest of the week I'll see you all the
week after next and you know I'll be on
social media and stuff so if y'all need
anything you just want to say what's up
you know I'll be there but won't be
around for streams but anyway thanks for
for coding with me or well doing the
audit stuff with me today I had a good
time and yeah hopefully I'll be back
soon and till then have a great day